there's only one thing I know about life
I know something's happened by chance
and some things happened because we make
them happen I am the future
happy fourth of July everybody they just
started the flash season 4 episode 1
they've been posting a whole bunch of
stuff from behind the scenes revealing
plot details as well as the big bad that
they're casting somebody even revealed
what they told him when he went in to
read for so let's break this down
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video we're just a couple weeks away
from Comic Con so we'll be watching this
footage in short order but danielle
panabaker was the first person to break
season 4 she posted this picture of her
parking spot so if you don't know what
this sign is you see the new logo for
season 4 they've already pasted it on
the production offices twitter account
so in another couple days or maybe when
we get closer to comic-con
they'll probably release the first
official poster but I do really like the
color contrast with the red of his suit
with the blue that they're putting
behind him it looks a little better than
the poster from last year which was
almost like a blown out red version
which gave you a little bit of a tension
headache if you stared at it for too
long but I do like the poses the flash
always has the best posters I missed
them doing the comic book covers back
from season 2 so maybe they'll bring
that back
but after Danielle posted this picture
the production office up in Vancouver
posted this picture of the first episode
revealing the title as the flash reborn
so big surprise they're not going to
call it rebirth and I think there are a
couple simple reasons why they did that
mostly for practical reasons because
after the speedforce storm berry got
sent up into the Speed Force so like he
has several times in the comics wally
west has done the same thing so we're
like okay they're going to do a version
of rebirth so we know where this is
going so one I think they went with a
slightly different title because they
wanted to invoke the idea of rebirth but
also at the same time letting you know
that they're not doing that exact comic
book arc like we don't want to confuse
people and think that god speed is going
to come because there's a new DC Reaper
and we don't want to confuse the older
comic book readers and make them think
that we're doing the Geoff Johns 2009
version of rebirth so it's a way for
them to play on the idea of the last
rebirth and Barry Allen coming back from
the Speed Force without intentionally
misleading you thinking they're doing a
specific comic book art like the way the
season 3
premiere was titled flashpoint but
didn't look anything like comic-book
flashpoint
so I think part of its also reaction to
the negative response to that so don't
be surprised when they do devote thinker
stuff from the comics this season but
they changed the titles just a little
bit from his comic book arc titles the
only people we know are going to be on
set on the first day our iris West who
said that she has to get really early
she's one of the earliest people that'll
be filming and danielle Panabaker who's
obviously on the lot already so even
though we know flash reborn implies a
flash rebirth twist where Barry comes
back I've already done a video on the
synopsis where they talk about a prison
break like rescuing him from his own
personal hell there's a lot of questions
that were raised by that so I'll link
that video at the end of this but the
really cool thing that we learned this
past weekend in a completely unrelated
event there was a game of Thrones
convention called Caan of Thrones if you
watch my Game of Thrones videos I talked
about it a little bit but the actor who
played Syrio Forel revealed that he read
for the flash season for Big Bad in the
way he teased it is like when he was
going to the casting agent and had to
read the lines like maybe you'll be this
new villain on the flash he said that
the pitch was the fastest man alive
versus the fastest brain alive so he
didn't reveal the character name that he
read for and I don't think that he reads
flash comics so I don't think that he
connected the dots that that is the
thinker because that's exactly who that
sounds like but when he was talking
about the character he was reading for
he described him as a fast talker really
smart and then he said the role really
wasn't for me the casting director gave
me three pages of random Roman trivia to
memorize and spit back out so we don't
really know how they're going to debut
the villain and how they're going to
weave them in with the big season long
arc because you have your big bad that
becomes a much bigger thing the second
half of the season but you also have a
couple of smaller villains the first
half of the season
so just because zoom was the big bad for
season 3 we still had the rival in the
first couple of episodes we still had
the new Rogues like mirror master and
top
I definitely think they're going to
introduce some more people from the
rogues gallery because I've already done
a video about Geoff Johns thinker arc
which basically turns into a matrix type
story because it was written after the
matrix came out Wally ends up defeating
the thinker using
neo versus man and black twist we're in
this cyber realm so it's actually pretty
cool you can actually scroll through my
flash season four video list if you want
to watch that but the storylines that
introduces that is called the new rogue
it's literally Geoff Johns introducing
all these new rogues for wally west to
face and then I think the first part of
the thinker's arc is issue number 184
and it's called crossfire and it just
goes over like a four or five issue
comic book run where that version of the
thinker is trying to expand the
processing power of his brain by
absorbing key stone and central city and
he slowly starts to do it before the
flash eventually defeats him just
remember the flash TV show changes a lot
of things from the comics so I'm
expecting them to pull from all the
different versions of the thinker going
back to the Golden Age so the big
takeaway is that it's a mastermind who
is very literally a mastermind so it's
somebody who can pull the strings of
more powerful rogue characters and
organize them in a way against the flash
that he's never seen before we'll find
out when we see that Comic Con trailer
in a couple weeks but I wouldn't be
surprised that they ramped his power
levels up like he starts out being
incredibly smart and then slowly gains
more power through the season it gets
crazier and crazier matrix style but
what's going to happen is is over the
next couple of days will actually see
pictures from the set so I'll just do
new videos depending on which characters
show up it'll confirm certain things
I'm expecting all the Bary scenes to
take place indoors just so they can
maintain the mystery of what's going to
happen with them and add to that fact
that when they're doing the speedforce
special effects they have all that
energy whirling around them that's all
green-screen so they have to film that
indoors anyway so you see people like
Candice Patton danielle Panabaker the
other actors saying that they're going
back to set just expect a little bit of
radio silence from Grant Gustin until he
actually appears on camera usually
that's what tips the Hat they're like
okay now we have to reveal that he's
back because somebody saw him on set but
you look at this picture here they're
getting ready to start day one of eight
so it'll be the entire next week we'll
be seeing stuff from the set of the
flash so leave all your requests for
bonus videos as for the Comic Con
trailer so rewatch just a little bit of
the season three Comic Con trailer and
they'll give you an idea for what
they're going to include in the season
for Comic Con trailer
I'm finally free oh hey slugger it's my
beautiful boy everything all right
kitchens great some people are just
meant to be in your life
hey who the hell is this this isn't your
home
arey it's a mirage it's already screwing
with you and everyone you love in prison
it's going to take me right down along
with you flashpoint
[Music]
the interesting thing about that you
might think that's only footage from
episode 1 but the dr. alchemy stuff was
from the end of episode 2 we didn't meet
him till then we heard his voice we
didn't really know what was going on and
it turns out that it was the voice of
Salvatore all along anyway but that
means that they'll probably include a
little bit of footage from episode 2 in
the Comic Con trailer but mostly episode
1 stuff so when I do my breakdown of
that in a couple weeks we'll just have
to guess which footage is from episode 1
which is from episode 2 but I think the
real question is is will they show berry
in the trailer I think that they have to
because could you imagine if they tried
to pitch a season to the flash where
they wanted to make people think that
the flash wouldn't come back there would
be riots in the street even though if
you're a comic book reader you know
exactly what's going to happen of course
he's going to come back eventually even
if you know how TV works so what will
happen is as we learn new stuff in the
set I'll do new videos believe all your
requests in the comments below there'll
be new Game of Thrones new Marvel new DC
posting really soon - congratulations -
Joshua Morris you're the latest giveaway
winner please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here to learn more
about episode 1 in my season 4 playlist
and you can click here for brand new
Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight